che figata essere con lo sfondo bianco
figo vi chiedo scusa se per questo video
e forse anche per qualche altro video
che uscirà vi sentirete con la voce
rimbombante non ci posso fare un cazzo
per adesso poi vi spiegherò il perchè
era arrivato il sushi
siamo su ragazzi pied de port se melo
sceso a youtube madonna rischia fin
bocca praticamente è un gioco dove devi
nascondere le riviste porno non c'è
niente di strano non ci sono puri non ci
sono per te non c'è un cazzo quindi mi
c'è solo nostro video devono morire ma
ora dico perché ultimato il fatto di del
genere successo quindi [ __ ] se lo
so n po il ragazzo da play bedroom che
sarebbero i due scenari da giocare per
fare stava sia nella bedroom sia
nell'ufficio facciamo nella bedroom ma
potevo fare fermi questa canzone ci hai
anche in un altro gioco quella gioco in
cui c'era vabbè sticazzi a devo
nascondere tutte le cose incriminate va
bene perché poi entra mia madre nella
stanza usate fazzoletti usati che schifo
cosa calzino quella la pa che ha visto
troppo mary campagna è che la storia
scogli porno nasconde
coi quelli erano i compiti mamma stavo
studiando il corpo umano a riproviamoci
devo capire il senso di star all africa
altro ci hanno fatto un gioco costa pure
sto gioco vi giuro su dio ragazzi sto
gioco costa un euro e venti che comunque
tanto per un gioco del genere va bè
fazzoletti usati non voglio sapere come
gli accusati ti sei pulito il culo spero
ma basta finito finito non c'è più
niente
giusto ma amava a posto guarda che sto
gioco sta giocando alla play che non era
la play però pazienza posto amica
livelli ma come qualcosa c'è il computer
che schifo quello non è il golden patto
di youtube o no quello di youporn e
centomila che schifo ma perché è tutto
sporco di bianco per terra mi chiama che
milani merda cifrate giovata cosa c'era
acer al telefono ma mica ama prendere un
dispositivo solo cassano perché tutti
quanti non puoi guardare i porno la
telefono e basta perché riguarda il
computer va bene jean perde però c'è
schifoso maledetto che ora dpa creato
madre corri
[Musica]
madonna che si è riuscita a nascondere
sasha grey il tempo che culo in bagno 8
secondi affogati cosa 86 con butta nel
cesso
ciao mamma sto facendo la cup che si
incazzata sempre quel problema ma da una
magia ma veramente la che checchi che
vide è guardato o se your bones dove lo
punti da fare per questo è il massimo
che c'è in questo videogioco in mio
aiuto mission sulla sta roba annuncia
giu roba entrò negli uffici gli sporco
tutti così ragazzi non ci posso credere
c'è questo guarda le cose sul televisore
sul telefono sulle riviste sulle altre
riviste non ce la faccio è possibile ma
che poi non ci mette un secondo nascondo
non ci metto pure nel tempo da anche
pensare dove nasconderli un idiota
porca eva bisogna dice sul biberon ha
l'opzione per le mani schifo come come
lo stai pulendo per come l'ho pulisci fa
terra così e non ce la puoi fare 06
lento sei lento mancia posso ragazzi in
tre azioni non si può fare suo livello
c'era ancora sporco per terra ma chrome
nella mia vita ho voluto fare lo
youtuber di gaming perché lo youtuber di
gaming quello con più dignità perfetto
nacque quella macchia l'imam è che
praticamente il bianchetto quando
studiavo raga anni anni di video di di
videogiochi per questo basta dire che va
bene with davano un quid così tanto era
ragazzi questo splendido gioco questo
spremi la categoria videoludica del 2017
che ci ricorda come ogni giorno e
videogiochi migliorino e che mi ricorda
ogni giorno il perché amo il mio lavoro
ha fatto non solo la play bedroom ma per
i giocatori più accaniti c anche il play
office che fai la stessa cosa in ufficio
non ho addosso sento al mio capo se
entra mia madre ogni caso entra non ho
idea pro veloce veloce in realtà è lui
solo cresciuto si riconosce dallo
sguardo questo mi guardi i porno sopra
l'armadio ceche problemi
vai vai bene nascondini a score di
fazzoletti pure pure veloce salve
capolavoro di oggi tutto completo io
lucidato anche le scarpe con uno
speciale lucidascarpe bianco ma d'ora
che brutto ufficio che qualche cattiva
gli scatoloni lì sembra uno sembra la
mia stanza mondo facile farli rispondere
che innescato lo tutti i regali
adesso abbiamo fatto come prima cosa sta
facendo boston sono i suoi servizi fino
a questo punto è bene che la promozione
importante però dotato questo è il bagno
nel bagno dell'ufficio dio santo che
schifo la scuola di veloce che con
arriva
[Musica]
come me lo merito questo posto di lavoro
non so neanche la cosa bella è che non
so come andrà intitolare questo video ci
penso adesso che sto giocando con la
consentito la restò video segue al
lavoro simulando anche se non so che poi
ragazzi questa non è tanto distante
dalla vita che faranno gli haters un
giorno però futuro degli haters
simulator quale problema però si fanno
ste cose
basta basta chi ha fatto questo gioco ed
evo devo saperlo
jack safety car hi macs 9 per ora corre
felice di giocare dx morri come hai
fatto a fare dieci minuti visto video
pensate che per arrivare io a dieci
minuti sto guardando i video degli altri
come possibile quante volte ho letto
questo titolo non devo dirlo questo
mouse scout mytouch in rai a vigevano
sembra di non essere sugli zero un più
energico grazie che mi è saltata la
connessione ringrazio gesù cristo
va bene voi non avete visto questo video
ogni giorno che passa sono simili sempre
più contento di farlo youtube
sono troppo contento ragazzi di aver
fatto questo video però mi detto
costretto purtroppo concludiamo
piuttosto di siete tristi e che avreste
potuto vedere che continuare a giocare a
sta roba
magari faranno una versione per guai
però capito gli sia piaciuta ragazzi
concluso che l'episodio
ora sembra che si sia piaciuto quel
momento non mi piace anche la risorsa
che come io totale descrizione mi
raccomando quando pulita la stanza
fatelo prima c'era se avessi di schiavi
richiesto un prossimo video bella
ragazzi
[Musica]